But is not it wrong to discriminate against people based on their religion?
But, Jamie, the problem
Uh, I mean, I'm with her
But, see ...
There are people coming to our country
They want to do a lot of damage
You look at
Look at Paris
Look at what happened in Paris.
I mean, these people, they did not come from Sweden
Concept?
Look at what happened in Paris
And what happened in California last week
With ... with, you know, fourteen dead people
The others will die
They are badly infected
We have a serious problem.
There is tremendous hatred abroad.
- And what I want to do is to know what
You know, you can not solve a problem
So you know the root cause
I want to know what the problem is
what is happening
This is temporary.
I had a lot of people call me and say thank you.
Now, as you remember, when you did it a week ago
It was like chaos.
Suddenly..
And you watched last night
And I saw them talking
They say, "Well, Trump has a point
We have to get to the problem. "
Friends who Accidentally,
They said
"Donald, I've done our tremendous service,
Because we have a problem
- And we must know what
And we have to know what you are - you might have been phone dumps
Those were probably telephone dumps-no-no
One of the charming things I found in Donald Trump
Is how his language is used
Different from the other candidates for the political post
Especially the President of the United States
While his opponents and the political class generally seem more aware that
Their words will be picked up and used against them
Trump deliberately underestimates this fact
As a lifelong seller, he has a bargaining talent to sell feeling
Even if the ideas and facts that confirm that they are false or racist or unclear
So I think it would be obvious to take a look at Trump answers to simple questions
In this case Jimmy Kimmel asked Trump whether it was wrong to discriminate against people based on their religion
In reference to a temporary proposal to block all Muslims from entering the United States
220 words, exactly one minute to answer
I think, a bunch of things that Trump is using all the time in his speech
The first thing to know is how simple this language is
Of the 220 words, 172, or 78%, in one section
They often come in a rhythmic series like a ball of footage ending with one of his buzzwords
"We must get to the problem"
39 words, or 17%, are two long sections
Only 4 words have three sections, 3 of which are massive, massive, and massive
And only two words are of 4 long clips
California, was forced to use it because it contained a lower section than San Bernardino
And temporarily, it is devouring
"And temporarily, I had a lot of people .."
This stop interferes with a study done by Boston Hearts
Which laid out all the presidential candidates' 2016 presidential candidates
Through the Fleisch-Kinkaid readability test to determine their grade level classifications
Donald Trump's speech came in fourth place from reading level
By reference, between Carson came in sixth
Hillary Clinton and the Bush-Kanu pocket speak eighth in the reading level
Bernie Sanders was in high school, in the second year, to be exact
Now this is not just for choosing a word or clip
It's about syntax as well
Trump's favorite simple sentences like:
"We have a real problem there, there is a huge number of hatred"
The sentence is rarely used as complex or independent sentences
He also prefers the second person most of the time, addressing listeners clearly with commands
"Look at Paris, look at what happened in Paris, look at what happened in Paris, see what happened in California last week"
Or involve us in what he will say as if we have already agreed
"And you saw yesterday, and I saw people talking"
Is really wonderful in this, framing the negative response as an overreaction that was later recognized as such
"As I remember, when I did this a week ago it was like chaos
Suddenly .. - You saw yesterday, and I saw people talking
They say, "Well, Trump has a point, we have to get to the problem."
Perhaps the most important method used by Trump and do it better than anyone I have heard
Is to end his sentence with strong words
Many times the sentence is initially arranged inappropriately, to enable it to end strongly
For example, here, perhaps it would be natural to say
You can not solve a problem until you find what is the root cause of it
But it brings them at the beginning to finish on the root cause
He does the same here
He seems to have done the same thing before Kimmel passes it
For these final words are important
They are routed and categorized together to draw the whole subject of the answer
"Damage, death, death, serious injury, problem, root cause
Thank you, mess, point, problem, service, problem "
In a sense, these are the words that the audience remembers
Especially when the rest of the speech is incoherent
Like the best seller, Trump keeps it simple, he repeats a lot
"We have a real problem, what is the problem
We have a problem, the problem must be reached "
He uses his favorite word repeatedly
"Massive, tremendous, tremendous service"
He always seems to have friends who are part of the group he is currently violating
They talk to him and thank him for excellence
"Many of them have happened to me and they said, Did you know, Donald? You're right, we have a problem and I see there's a problem."
Donald Trump knows when it sounds painful or strong ...
He has a good comic instinct, you can even call him a comic
But you can not give him intelligence or knowledge
The best seller may sell you a TV without knowing anything about it
Because television does not matter
Important, it is you.
And if you are an American citizen, for years
The politicians may have listened to the sound of sophistication while doing nothing
You may be just getting ready for something
That's not all.
But next time if I feel that Donald Trump has a point
Do yourself a service
And look at his words.
Hi everyone, Thanks for watching. I want to point you in the direction of my friends, Wise Crack
They did a great job, and fantastic article videos. If you like what you have, you will certainly
She likes what they do. They talk about books, movies, and my favorite personally is the 8-bit philosophy
It is like philosophy illustrated with Nintendo graphics. Very good. I wish I had thought about it.
Anyway, go to them, sign up, watch a clip, if you want to help me as usual.
You can click here, and donate $ 1, 2, 3, or $ 5 to my channel.
I'm excited to see you Wednesday in the next video and I'll see you.